les usagers s'en souviendront longtemps
hier après midi à lapproche bizac alors
que le soleil est encore largement au
rendez vous le réseau de bus mosaïque
est arrêté alors qu'aucune consignes
préfectorales n'a été donnée dans ce
sens et lève employés personnes âgées
aux mères de famille tous doivent
regagner leur domicile par leurs propres
moyens
cette décision de la crt us sur avis des
représentants syndicaux n'en finit plus
de susciter des réactions parfois au
plus haut niveau
je partage l'indignation de la
population qui a été la première victime
de cette décision unilatérale
j'avais pris des décisions qui étaient
très clairs à savoir nous étions en
alerte orange
les établissements scolaires les
établissements petite enfance devait
fermer mais en aucun cas en aucun cas la
situation ne justifiait que l'on ferme
ainsi les activités et les premières
victimes ont été les usagers qui ont été
laissées en plan
je dis les choses et donc moi j'ai bien
l'intention d'entrer en contact avec la
cft eu pour en discuter et voir comment
on peut organiser ce qu'on appelle la
continuité du service public
la direction de la cft us e tr dans le
silence
ce sont les syndicats qui rassemblés
aujourd'hui livrent leurs explications à
commencer par le site des almadies
potentiellement exposées à la houle nous
sommes quoi à 5-6 mètres de la mer et
que quand il ya la houle
la houle du x 5,5 6 5 6 m dalmat dis
donc nous avons des mécaniciens qui
travaille juste à côté
nous avons quand même du 320 volts et
que bombay quand on a fait le travail
par rapport à un attrapé vie etc
c'est oublier sont organisés pour ces
syndicats
les consignes de sécurité doivent
s'appliquer avec la même constance pour
tous scolaires entreprises ou services
publics
moi c'est la loi si si qui doit rentrer
chez lui si monsieur décide de faire de
son magasin me préparer pour nous aussi
il faut une donnée ignoble on a décidé
la direction pas prendre des initiatives
ils peuvent pas fait une communication
cotonou pour la clientèle voici ce qui
s'est passé on n'avait pas le choix
vous n'êtes pas un magasin vous avez une
mission de service public c'est ça
monsieur laisse la voie publique
on a quand même l'un des douze mètres
des 24 m aujourd'hui quand on donne du
passé pour un des problèmes avec la
direction de travail en vue du super g
est chez nous on aime bien et il faut
pour cela que ce qu'on anticipait la n2
est coupée la norme au bout de la
journée
donc non anticipés pouvoir faire de la
batterie vous à protéger le fabuleux au
mieux l'intérêt particulier de
l'entreprise et de ses salariés semblent
ici se confronter directement à
l'intérêt général de la population de la
cacem des réflexions devraient être
engagés pour intégrer les entreprises de
transport au plan orsec de la préfecture
pour plus de cohérence à l'avenir